hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
september
12th
2022
[Music]
what's going on how are ya
[Applause]
[Music]
it has happened football season has
officially started
how amazing
how you what's amazing is you cannot
[ __ ] believe it
and then like within like i don't know
what like an hour it just already feels
like it's been football season the whole
year
like i thought the whole game i was
going to be like oh my god it gave me a
much attacker
it didn't
it didn't
within an hour of watching for it i'm
like why the [ __ ] are they going for it
here that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
i don't know what the [ __ ] are you doing
oh nice play nice play
that's what happens to me
that's me watching a football game you
see this right here this is this new
goddamn way of [ __ ] coaching it makes
no goddamn sense well go go go go that's
what i do
you're kicking away here you're kicking
away oh first down yes
the [ __ ] i'm talking about
when you're old that's how you watch
your football game
uh speaking of old i'm watching tom
brady and i'm he's finally looking at
least like he's played in the league for
12 years
you know
he looks like that that guy in blink 182
now i feel like if he played uh is it
thomas de long
um
angela's ashes
angels in the outfield
um anyway
i [ __ ] missed all the football
i mean i missed just about everything
because uh you know i'm just i'm i'm
just
[ __ ] crazy busy till
the 23rd the 20 after the 23rd september
my [ __ ] life slows down
then my life slows down it slows down
all right
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm just
gonna tell everybody i have covered
and then they'll leave me alone right
and then when they call back after five
hey just checking in just to see i i got
it again i'm just gonna keep saying i
got covered and then i'm gonna say
monkey pox and i feel if i do that i'm
good
until november
um
i just had a [ __ ]
incredible time
out on the road i got to do one of my
favorite cities
tulsa oklahoma
um unfortunately i didn't get to do too
much while i was there i did find a good
coffee spot
which is pretty easy to do by the way
um oh you know now that i'm i'm new to
coffee since march
all right way back when i was 53 i'm 54
now okay i've the the the odometer has
flipped since i started drinking coffee
back in march it's not that hard to find
good coffee
with the internet i don't understand why
people just go
like why do they just [ __ ] go to to
to to the [ __ ] starbucks starbucks
stinks
just burning the beans
i'm telling you i i i'm a [ __ ] coffee
snob already and my deal is if you can't
make a [ __ ] double espresso
then i don't want to i don't want
anything else you have in that place i
don't want to know you i don't want to
talk to you i don't want to set foot in
your [ __ ] i think you should be shut
down
no it's not that bad but i basically
i just read some reviews when they get
the five stars four and a half to five
stars you got a really good chance that
they can make a great espresso and um
i found a place in tulsa i found a place
i then went down to houston
had a great time down there
uh got to walk around a little bit in
that city i like to walk around the city
rather than
get on like a treadmill hello i did do
the elliptical this morning but i like
to uh you know
try to find a place you know about a
mile away it's a 15-minute walk out
15-minute walk back you know
i'm gonna get a bunch of emails dude
takes you 15 minutes what's it like to
be old
um
well if you don't jaywalk and put your
life in your [ __ ] hands yeah it'll
take you about 15 minutes going up and
down the hill i went to this place in
tulsa it was pretty cool i i walked over
a bridge
came down and there was some sort of
weed store you couldn't even see the
sign for it and actually walked around
the back because i thought the front was
a weed store and it came in
and lo and behold i was drinking a
liquid death
and the barista look at me learning all
the young people words
the baristas said what did he said nice
choice
nice choice and i want to be like you
[ __ ] telling me nice choice i'm the
guy i've been shilling this [ __ ]
[ __ ] talking to me like all of a
sudden he discovered something
you know
i found this band first you know what
it's football season i'm moving this
[ __ ] chair back and i'm sitting in
i'm sitting in the archie bunker chair
when i do this [ __ ] podcast all right
i've had it it's football season
football season means you as an
unathletic man titted father get to sit
in a big brown chair like you hunted for
big game in africa and you sit down and
you watch the late game on sunday night
and all your loved ones know better
they know better to keep their [ __ ]
distance oh am i gonna put my feet up i
think i am this right here is america
this is a mammoth this is you know
america this is right now how america is
i'll tell you [ __ ] china took us over
they would know good and goddamn well
everything that they [ __ ] took they
couldn't take this away if they took
this away they'd have to [ __ ]
they'd have to deal with a lot ah jesus
um
i've been looking at guns lately
you know i've been working out and every
morning when i brushed my teeth the
[ __ ] biceps are really
really coming on i'm kidding i'm i'm
[ __ ] uh yeah
i think i'm gonna buy a 38 i like a 38
you know i wish i still was 38. it's
only six bullets and i like the idea of
like hiding behind my ottoman after i
missed the first six you know pushing it
back with my head like in an action
movie as i [ __ ]
you know try to reload it again i mean i
just grew up on shows like that that's
what you did you found something that
wasn't bulletproof and you turned your
back on your target and you
you spilled the bullets down by that's
how it was done
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
yeah i think it's a good way to go
because
eventually the ponzi scheme collapses
and then i live out here in a desert
that has no water supply so eventually
and we really don't have any game out
here so you're gonna pretty s you're
gonna have to eat other your neighbors
pretty quickly unless you band together
with them and then you go neighborhood
to neighborhood
type of fighting or whatever i think
that's how it's going to go down bill
what happened we were talking football
you're right you're right we were hey
let's um
let's talk uh
fenway park merch
is now available uh baseball tease and
win breakers
use the link in the podcast descript
description
i guess he's gonna post that um
so there you go
we had a few things left over from the
uh the fenway park show
um
so you'll be able to buy them we'll have
the link right there with the podcast
evidently however the hell that works so
i was not able to all i watched was the
highlight
of my super bowl pick and everybody
else's out of the afc
is the buffalo bills and they went up
against the defending super bowl
champions in week one on a thursday
night and evidently they went back and
forth for a minute and then just
they just took over the game i guess
their defense
from the highlights the defense looked
amazing
josh allen ended in a ram quarterback's
career with a stiff arm
and then they just by the i guess by the
second half they just beat the [ __ ] out
of them
and um
yeah i i really
really like their chances because i feel
like the afc west they're just gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of each other
going well they don't really do that
anymore the one game i did watch
i watched the second half of the
churches
first the las vegas euradis
new babies
um kick us up and it's good
902 into the first quarter dallas draws
first blood
all the small things
um tom brady i'm next
um
say it ain't so
i will not go
turtle like dog carry me
that's [ __ ]
right there and i mean if you want to
get nine million people going nuts i
mean that that's a melody right there i
i
i stand by that
i like a good pop [ __ ] song
i'm sick of all these [ __ ] deep cut
sons of [ __ ] trying to make me feel
like i don't know what music is i never
said i knew what music was
okay i have a very simple brain okay
it's a straight six
okay
if you just go
[Music]
there i'll do it with you
i'm not questioning anything
you know
being dumb isn't bad if you admit it
you know and people actually they'll
help you out if you just [ __ ] say
listen man i'm not the brightest guy oh
he's stupid let's help him it works
it's been working for me for a long time
um anyway so after i went to tulsa
um
you know this is a big tour next time
i'm telling you next time i'm coming
around i'm talking my agent all right
it's like i'm not my [ __ ] doing these
big
gigantic [ __ ] i'm gonna be
doing like
staying in a um
in a uh like you know
stay in some place for a couple two
three days i'm not gonna just go to
tulsa [ __ ]
you know
fly and do the show and then leave what
the [ __ ] the point of going to tulsa
it's annoying and then i found out the
next day the oklahoma sooners had a
whole game i would have drove over to
norman unless they had the flex schedule
the flex schedule the [ __ ]
money grubbing [ __ ] just tell me what
time the [ __ ] game is
i gotta stand halfway through second and
third to see if the ball's going to drop
kids i've nobody's ever answered me this
question why the [ __ ]
do you go you're on second base
there's no outs somebody hits a fly ball
to right field why do you just
automatically go halfway
why do you do it because he drops it
he's not gonna [ __ ] drop it
and you've completely eliminated your
ability to ever tag up
like what if he catches it but then
falls on his ass
you're still not gonna get third i think
that that makes no [ __ ] sense the
same way
when i watch the second half of the san
diego ch i'm sorry the los angeles
churches
first to las vegas
um
this was my assessment
as someone who hasn't played organized
sports since the fifth grade
um i got a d in math ended my career
um
i i as much as they picked off derek
carr three times
and made him fumble twice
i just thought that i just saw a lot of
big chunk yardage maybe that's how the
game is now
i mean it's been like that but let's
just a lot of just stiff arms and
charges just falling on their backs like
who the [ __ ] was that guy on the raiders
like he would catch like a little
[ __ ]
a little out on the flat and then he
just would go beige
like to two to three guys and they would
just all fall in the back as he ran
diagonally for a first down
um i i don't know
well it is the first who gives a [ __ ]
it's the first game of the week and you
guys are you the first week of the
season i should say and you listen to a
stand-up comedian so what do i know
um
but you know i'm doing that bet mgm
thing going up against the great paul
version the returning champion from last
year we bet against the spread
um
and we go face to face for the jimmy the
greek award um he won it last year and i
don't know how he did this week
i think we might have both gone two and
two
i took the uh i took the chargers
and won that
one i took the ravens which was the gift
of the week against the jets
and
then i took
arizona against the chiefs because i
said that the chiefs notoriously start
slow
oops
um i don't know about you but as a
football fan i kind of like a pissed off
patrick mahomes
um my patriots got
i don't know i guess we did it right in
the first half but then we just kind of
you know it's gonna you know it's gonna
be like i think we're gonna be okay
we're gonna be competitive before it
gets better i'm hoping uh
you know we still have the greatest
coach of all time or at least since uh
i would say uh
paul brown
and paul brown is the right choice if
you're talking championships and
changing the game
and longevity and success
and uh in a nice head of hair you got to
go paul brown
um
but i got to be honest with you it's
kind of nice like
being like middle of the pack
nobody [ __ ] paying attention to you
espn not talking about you anymore it's
it's it's kind of nice
could just sort of sit down you know
throw some money on some games
you know watch the rebuilding process i
love a rebuilding process i'm enjoying
watching what the red sox are doing
they're bringing a bunch of people up
from worcester
out there near the akua coo
the long sense the funk chinese
restaurant that was some good [ __ ]
food if you're an old mass hole like me
they had one location in worcester they
had another one in cambridge and both of
them had a great function room
um does anybody know how to [ __ ]
tackle any i guess you can't you gotta
lead with your shoulder
you have to signal i don't know what
you're supposed to do it's it's just
it's a different game
i saw brady was saying he was talking
about how the game changed how it was
really physical
and now it's more uh
i guess performance
yes bill we've watched football as long
as you have all right all right relax
why doesn't everybody just [ __ ] relax
so then i went down to houston
after i went to tulsa for probably the
third or fourth time
and i didn't uh i still have yet to go
to the outsiders house
which is something i want to do
i also want to ride a harley-davidson
road king
around the outskirts of a city like that
you know where there's not a whole bunch
of traffic and that type of [ __ ] that's
one that's one of my bucket list things
to do to be
out there
you know
just driving by a bunch of
[ __ ] donald trump signs
and american flags and all that hardly
you know out in the sticks
you know what i mean i feel like i've
driven a prius by enough obama in joe
biden signs i think i need to see the
other half of america
nice [ __ ] tackle
right in the backfield
you know the old me i was just in dallas
last night
saturday night that is and the old me
would have had out the football schedule
going wait a minute wait a minute the
[ __ ] cowboys are playing taunt the
tom brady buccaneers i gotta go see that
[ __ ] game however
um
i got the kids to come home to now man
so i came home
it was awesome they came running down
the stairs tackled me
and they basically used me as like a
bouncy house
is what i find i think part of it's my
problem because i get down on the floor
with them and then they just start
jumping on me
so i was playing with my son and then my
daughter like literally leaps up in the
air and lands on my shoulders
and i let out a scream because i was
anticipating throwing out my back and
nothing happened so it was kind of
startled everybody i just went like i
went
ah
which
when she did it and um
fortunately nothing happened but um
kids are [ __ ] hilarious man i mean as
a dude did they ever not hit you in the
junk
i mean they can be on the other side of
the room throw something it hits you in
the junk
they come over to hug you and they come
like from the side and as they go to
grab you they just punch you in the dick
it's just [ __ ] unbelievable they go
to jump off you they lose their footing
and just step right on your junk
it's
[Laughter]
i'm about to go to a sporting goods
store and buy a cup um
but anyway it it's
awesome to be back i had a great time
when i was out in dallas uh i had
so many friends that came out and then
other people that i didn't see i
actually went by i was really cool i
went by gas monkey garage
um
i came down i got to meet
the [ __ ] one and only uh richard
rawlings
and he gave me this nice tour of the
place and uh he just had a really really
really [ __ ]
cool badass collection of cars where he
had everything
from the [ __ ] everybody wants
to obscure stuff
to then my favorite just random weird
[ __ ]
like he had like a 72 crew cab tow truck
and it was a ford
um then he had a couple of uh some of
these older cars
that i just didn't picture him you know
that being in his wheelhouse but like
like
his appreciations of cars goes all the
way all the way all the way back
um
what else then he had a sick ass let's
this [ __ ] 1978
red trans am
with the t-tops
the [ __ ]
flaming eagle whatever the [ __ ] it is on
the hood man bad ass car
he had this other pin he had a ford
pinto that i love that was jacked up in
the back
you know when they used to put the
[ __ ] giant slicks on the back it was
all about jacking up the rear end and
putting the giant tires getting all that
rubber on the road
um
yeah it was really cool got to do that
kind of did that we drove up from
houston
swung by saw that and then we went and
we did the show and um
i worked with uh bianca chris davao
she [ __ ] killed it the whole weekend
and uh
got me to go to the gym this morning so
that was a that was a two-for-one there
um
i don't know but oh billy boy's gotta
lift some life here once once i once i
[ __ ]
i'm almost done with this movie
uh putting this movie together and we've
been showing the trailer at my shows
getting a great response very excited
about that but uh
i gotta go live some life
you know because uh i'm getting sick of
my act
it's getting a little stale there um
but speaking of which i'm going to two
[ __ ] fun comedy cities next week i'm
going to dc and i go to uh philadelphia
so that'll be good another [ __ ]
flight across the country
i swear to god
remember towards the end of his life
michael jackson would just sleep in that
[ __ ] tank
you know
and just use like [ __ ] that [ __ ] if
you're getting your appendix out
anesthesia
i don't understand why they just don't
do that to everybody on the plane we
have a very full flight and everybody
just deals with that everybody puts the
bags in the overhead compartment and
then when they go to take off you just
[ __ ] just put everybody to sleep
there would be no that would never be no
more hijackings
you know no more fights on the plane
no more people
fighting over [ __ ] armrests they just
put you out
okay everybody
turning on the gas
just turn on the gas
and then all of a sudden it's just a
gentle hand shaking your shoulder
hey we're in new york
oh oh really oh great oh thanks
that be so hard
um well bill you could always
self-medicate i used to do that
when i just couldn't go across the
country again i used to just start
pounding [ __ ] booze
if i get like a a cool like male
stewardess
or a stewardess whatever the [ __ ] you
call stewards
a steward and a stewardess oh
interception now we dropped it
um
yeah
i had a couple flights like that
with someone
like knew my act and they were
they were a fan of it thank god
maybe they weren't they were doing
something on my drinks or whatever but
they they just would just start [ __ ]
bringing them and
i remember one flight in particular
where i i had maybe
i think six doubles
bourbons
i just kept pounding them
and i never passed out
and but i had a great time
i forget where i was going obviously and
i just got off i got off the plane
[ __ ] hammered and i remember i met
the driver [ __ ] hammered
yeah that's when i was going out of
control there was another time i boost
on a flight and i ended up [ __ ]
talking to a passenger and he drove me
home
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was getting a little sideway it's
good that i don't drink anymore
it's good that i don't [ __ ] drink
anymore
um
so
anyway um
i just completely lost my train of
thought here we have no reads this week
i don't know what i've done i think i've
pissed off all of my advertisers like
how do you what nobody wants to sell
anything this week
you don't have anything to sell i have
things to sell i have fenway park
merchandise
which is now available
baseball tees and windbreakers this is
just for people who might be walking by
in the background if you have this on
speakers hey
i got windbreakers and baseball tees use
the link in the podcast description
um
yeah i got to be honest with you out of
all of texas uh i think i'm a dallas guy
i really
like
dallas
i like how much they give a [ __ ] about
the cowboys i like the cowboys
um
you know
it's a clean city
you can [ __ ] live out there for like
you know
a decent amount of money
you're out drew pearson
michael irvin they both were 88 look at
that
um
sorry commercial in the background um
no i think if i was gonna like if i was
gonna live
uh
you know it gets cold a little bit
sometimes it snows right
be still but i i don't wanna move to
another drought [ __ ]
state if i was gonna do that you know
i don't know bill what are you talking
about you're talking drought in your
state you're talking about getting a gun
what are you doing man
riding a harley through [ __ ]
trump cities
can the republicans don't have anybody
else that they can [ __ ] throw our way
you know the democrats can't just be
like joe biden is uh he's a little
[ __ ] loopy can't get rid of him you
can't why don't we just can we just like
clean the slate and just start over
again
do like uh you know like when teams
rebuild
can we send like can we act like we're
the marlins
you know and just dump our whole team
and just let the dodgers and yankees
pick up everybody or the lakers yeah
let's send trump and biden to the lakers
and we'll start over
for a couple of draft picks and we'll
just start over again maybe maybe people
could like each other again and maybe
along the way we could get rid of fox
news and [ __ ] cnn and they would stop
stirring people up every single [ __ ]
day
god damn it can you let people get along
i gotta be honest i've
lived a long time at this point 54 years
i've never seen it like that like it is
it's [ __ ] bananas
um
like those maniacs that like i mean
there was always maniacs but jesus
christ
if you know if you could just let go of
your political party for a second and
just be impartial and just really think
of the [ __ ] behavior on both sides
over the last [ __ ] i don't know
what five six years i mean [ __ ]
lunatics
on both sides just [ __ ] lunatics
i don't know what do you do about it
i always have these fantasies that
there's like this elite hit squad
that could just go around
and like kill all the morons and i don't
mean like meatheads i don't mean like
just [ __ ] sport i mean like
like morons i'm talking
sociopaths
and the people that follow them
[Laughter]
um
yeah
i don't know all right it's this it's
getting too [ __ ] dark see this is why
this is why usually
at this point
we have we have a little bit of
advertising i cleanse the palette and
then i get into your [ __ ] ideas
that's that's what i usually end up
doing
um
i'm actually reshooting a once we're
adding a scene to the movie and then
we're reshooting another one we just got
to add like one more joke to which i
i've learned is a common practice
in making movies so i'm pretty excited
i'm excited about the people that we
cast for tomorrow so tomorrow we're
shooting a couple of scenes and then uh
i got another busy day the next day but
then i'm going to a movie that i'm
really excited to see
that one of the actors that's in old
dad's
bobby carnivale is in
it's called blonde i believe it's called
blonde it's about uh it's just really
i guess
i don't know accurate dark whatever you
want to call it um
a movie about marilyn monroe and i
believe bobby gets to play
uh joe dimaggio which is pretty [ __ ]
cool
because uh he's a huge yankee fan
she reminded me a lot not so much during
the second half of the season but the
first half of the season
you know i heard i heard a lot from him
we were uh we were fast friends
and now it's more of a long-distance
relationship i'm kidding i'm getting
he's [ __ ] promoting his movies so uh
i'm gonna go see that
there's a little premiere down the
street oh [ __ ]
oh billy [ __ ] uh
star search
it's gonna go down there
are you guys like me when i go to a
movie i eat like a [ __ ] animal
i eat like a [ __ ] animal i'll get
like two things of candy a giant popcorn
and a [ __ ] massive soda and my body
like three minutes in is going stop
stop and i go all right all right i go
to stop and i don't
i just keep [ __ ] going
i don't know
i would never eat that way at home i
would never eat that way like there's
something about it you're not home the
lights are off
you can just hide in there and just be
the [ __ ] animal that you really are
there's been a couple times
back when i used to work out and go to
the gym and do [ __ ] like that before
i don't know what happened over the last
[ __ ] year um
i would be so into working out that when
i would go to a movie i would not eat
anything
and i would just have a [ __ ] water
and i would sit there
sipping that [ __ ] water
i mean
i mean i would love to hear what the
average calorie intake
is for the person that goes to a movie i
mean i'm definitely sending it to the
roof there's no way i'm not in four
figures
when i go see a movie
a couple boxes of candy and like a
[ __ ] bag of popcorn and a soda forget
it i mean that's like probably like what
1400
every douche on the podcast listening
right now 14
[ __ ] try 2100
yeah bud have fun losing a toe
three to three at this point
three to three
tom brady three to three i say brady
comes along he's gonna win this one
i think i'm a patriots fan i can't root
against this guy here we go number three
number three lining up lining up i can't
believe they didn't go for it in today's
nfl boom bang six to three
tampa bay on top
um all right let's get to some of your
uh
what did i just do here let's get to
some of your um
questions here oh you know what
when i when i went to the gas monkey he
told me that you can i didn't realize
this you can order an f-250 short bed
like they'll make it
i was like i didn't [ __ ] know that
but then again i don't i didn't want
that anyways i like the i want to have
that stock regular cab eight foot bed
but for half a second he had me thinking
about it
and he was saying you should get the
[ __ ]
the f250 super duty do uh dooley
i think it's an f450 if it's a dually
right with the short bed and i actually
went online
and looked up and someone made one
and i got to admit
i it's so [ __ ] cool and also at the
same time ridiculous it literally looks
like a combination of a tonka truck
or something like that you'd use to tow
an airplane back in the 70s
i might i'm gonna post the video um
it's pretty
i don't know
i don't know i showed it to somebody and
she was just like why what what would
you do with that little part in the back
that little thing in the back
[Music]
it's like nothing you don't do anything
with it you just drive around looking
cool that's the old that's the sole
purpose
of that thing but these people of course
when they built it they put some sick
ass engine in the thing and they were
doing like a [ __ ] burnout
um
i hate burnouts
i really do i always just look like why
are you doing that to those tires
it's just a [ __ ] waste man come on
the air is polluted enough we got it we
can hear it we know it's strong
um
anyway i will post that uh
i will post that video uh oh look who it
is everybody wait a minute what is this
why don't why the [ __ ] that these are
reeds no
what the f oh my god did i do what i
think i just did
how do i do this
why do i do this my stand-up special
from years ago did i accidentally
[ __ ] erase my [ __ ]
today's not nine eight god damn it
what in the [ __ ] did i do with it how do
you [ __ ] accidentally erase something
bill you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] i do this all
the [ __ ] time
and then i flip out and act like it's
not just one quick phone call to my to
to the wonderful andrew females
jesus christ
here we go i know he's watching this
game
hang on a second everybody let me
[ __ ] make this happen here
it's six to three by the way everybody
101 to go in the first quarter
hey i somehow i don't know i'm doing the
podcast right now i'm literally doing
the podcast right now like this phone
call is on
the podcast legally in california i have
to let you know that that you're on a
podcast right now
um i somehow erased the content can you
send send it to me so i don't keep
[ __ ] stuttering here on the podcast
all right cool all right thank you
all right just like that see that i
started to flip out no bill you did flip
up well for me that was starting to flip
up okay
i started the flip up
um
pissed off patrick mahomes who do they
have next week see this is the first two
weeks are the two hardest weeks to
gamble on i feel like after two weeks
you can kind of figure it out
right
like i don't know who the [ __ ] chiefs
have next week
but i feel like a lot of gamblers are
going to be like dude they look like
world beaters it's going to be the
chiefs versus the bills just like last
year and ah all this type of [ __ ]
uh which it
very well maybe i i don't know
but uh
i would stay away from the chiefs next
week although this week i said they'd
start off slow
so if you're a chiefs fan right now you
have to be loving me
because i'm staying with
i bet against you and now i'm saying
stay against stay away from your your
team which is two negatives towards your
team which equals a positive i think you
start off
well i can't now if i say that then
you're going to lose
i was going to say that i think that you
guys might start off two and out there i
said it i don't give a [ __ ] i don't have
that kind of power if i did i would win
more bets all right i got it back here
all right
drinking water
yo billy red sock
um
if you haven't heard about the drinking
water crisis in jackson mississippi it's
because the news isn't covering it no i
saw it
uh there is brown water coming out of
the faucet some instances it looks like
sludge well what happened
if you want to know how
it's being handled you're not alone the
national guard should be driving
tanker trucks of clean water in but
they're not we should rename jackson to
new ukraine so maybe someone would give
a [ __ ] in washington or on twitter
i know isn't that amazing
where are all the hollywood liberals
who give a [ __ ] about everything they
don't give a [ __ ] they only care
if you have on a blue [ __ ] tie but
conversely
you guys out in jackson you know when
our whole [ __ ] state's on fire you
guys are all out there that's cause
they're a bunch of [ __ ] pedophiles
banging fetuses inside a [ __ ]
infinity pool up in the hollywood hills
we should all be helping each other out
um
anyway this person says luckily for me
i'm two hours away and my family has
well water we've bought lots of water to
affected friends and family we've
brought lots of water but that's all we
can do if i had lots of money i'd take
out tv ads publicly shaming everyone in
charge
because all these people go nameless who
[ __ ] everything up do you have any good
ideas
um
i think what you're doing is a good idea
writing in like podcasts and that type
of stuff
um and i also think that what you did
was great
which is you're helping out your fellow
americans
when they need help
and i honestly believe
that
all of us know
that it doesn't matter
what color the tie is that the person
wears
or the bra
or whatever they wears
and chooses to wear because it's
everybody's right the [ __ ] feel
comfortable in their clothes
um
none of them work for us
they all act like they do and they go
joe six-pack you guys out here you put
your pants on one leg at a time it's all
[ __ ] lip service the end of the day
they are grossly underpaid they're
grossly underpaid
and they want a big [ __ ] house
all right
so that makes them susceptible to bribes
and they work for special interest
groups giant corporations the bankers
the oil companies all of this [ __ ]
that's who the [ __ ] they work for so the
bottom line
is
you know politicians
failed everybody a long [ __ ] time ago
and um
you know i think it's really easy to
just walk around going like these
[ __ ] democrats these [ __ ] libtards
did this or these these [ __ ]
conservatives are just oh my god just
horrible people and just act like
you don't have any power as an
individual
i think if if people actually tried to
employ
like you know
i am one person i'm gonna try to help
one person and not not and i don't mean
like okay i'm driving to work
and there's some dusty human being
standing by my window like a [ __ ]
zombie and i'm gonna give him five bucks
today i mean if that's all you can do
that's all you can do but i you know
i think all of us
most of us
including me are not involved in any
sort of program where you take time out
during your week to help people out
and uh i think there's a very small
portion of people
that do that and i think if
everybody did that i think we could
change the vibe in this country
and we could maybe freak out the [ __ ]
people up top now they would they would
they would figure out a way to pit us
against each other
again um
but if we never bought into it
i don't know i don't know what their
[ __ ] game is because i have no
problem
with somebody ruling over me
it's just when
they they have this insatiable no matter
how much power and how much money they
have it's never enough
so um
all right here's one if anybody's out
there and knows of this is the hardest
thing
you know i have a i have a production
company we can do a benefit show
to raise
you know some money to get some fresh
water out there or something like that
get a [ __ ] truck out there
maybe we could do this somebody know
like how how would you how do you do
that
there's got to be a way to do that
maybe we could look into that i could do
a stand-up show we could uh
you know then you try to create
something that everybody can donate to
and then there's like taxes like how the
[ __ ] do you do this and all of that and
meanwhile people need the water now i
don't know
i'm open to any ideas
that you guys might have and
um
i got to shoot this thing tomorrow one
of my my business people will be down
there and i will bring that up to them
um
i will say this year we the one [ __ ]
thing
i feel that i was able to do this year
was uh
we've got a bunch of school supplies
at a public school
and uh which is the best way because if
you try to give money it just goes to
the main
fund and then they it doesn't go to the
school you're actually trying to help it
goes into some sort of main it's really
difficult so the best way i found to
help out a
a public school if you want to is just
to go to you know if you somehow run
into a teacher
and she just tells you the supplies they
need then you go out and you get them
and you give right to their you know
this teacher was really psyched that it
happened so
um i think your email is
100
on point
and
um
why aren't they helping them out
i can tell you why they're not helping
them out is because then jackson
mississippi doesn't make the people that
can call the national guard enough money
that's what it is mississippi has been a
state
that the united states gave up on a long
[ __ ] time ago
um
i don't think the north ever cleaned up
their mess after uh
the civil war i don't think we ever did
anything to really try to mend
things and uh i also think that we use
the south as a scapegoat like only
racist white people live down there
and that everybody up north is this
[ __ ] you know
great person
there's a lot of problems but you know
what we could use this [ __ ] problem
as a way to maybe turn it around look at
that huh it's not bad for a meathead
that was pretty good little soliloquy
there
um
who's got a [ __ ] water truck and how
much does it cost to fill up
there we go
who's got a [ __ ] truck
we need some people with trucks let's
get some [ __ ] water down there
and then we'll just write something on
the side that shames them
like this is what you should have been
doing
they'll probably figure out how to stop
him at the border
um let's do that so somebody got a who's
got a giant [ __ ] water truck hang on
a sec i gotta go look this up
can richard rawlings make us a [ __ ]
water truck
uh
let me see something
water
truck
rental
let's see here
let's look at images
i want a big [ __ ] tanker
there we go
water truck 2 000 gallons
all right next search
here we go
how much does it cost to fill up
a 2 000 gallon water truck
i'm sorry i didn't understand the
question
water truck rental costs
four thousand five thousand
a gallon how much does it cost to hire a
water truck
final facts about water truck
for rent low minimum
water truck is simply a truck that has
been fitted with the large strength okay
we know what it is
water trucks and special inlets
how much does it cost to hire a water
truck
the cost varies all over the country
with that said you can expect to pay
around 400
400 bucks for two two thousand gallons
of water they can't do that for these
people
the cost of filling a ten thousand
gallon
pool on your local not a pool
all right
all right we're gonna do this
400 bucks
for two
for 2 000 gallons
all right slow down slow down your brain
bill so for five trucks two grand for
two grand i can get five trucks to go
down there i gotta make this happen
when i finish this podcast
i want to do this this is like a 1970s
movie can we get chris christopherson to
[ __ ] drive it in this is a rubber
duck coming in with your clean water we
got a bear in the air um let's make it
happen
what the [ __ ] are we doing here
if i find this is as easy as looking it
up like that what why not what the [ __ ]
do i care government's taking all my
goddamn money anyway i don't give a [ __ ]
you know
what you guys do if i sent him there and
i put my face all over the truck
[Music]
and i use it as a way to promote myself
and my career and on the back of the
truck it was just my freckled fingers
making the form of a heart you know
those douches who take they make those
instagram
photos we make the heart with your
fingers in your thumb
um
all right well then wait this isn't is
it that then we'd have to [ __ ] now we
got to get a parking lot you can't just
just drive there and start spraying
water people you gotta get it there
all right
whatever
the idea is in motion i'm not saying i'm
gonna [ __ ] make i'm gonna i don't
know how to do it i'm gonna figure out
how to do it it's gonna happen
all right
as far as i'm going to figure out how to
do this it's hilarious
right after somebody called but he's
going to think i'm calling about the uh
the shoot tomorrow
what's your shot list tomorrow this has
nothing to do with that let's say we
rent a 2 000 gallon water truck for 400
bucks to fill it then we rent the truck
we have the guy drive it there it's
gonna be more than two grand because
it's gonna be gas and all of that [ __ ]
um
i actually know a bus driver that
[ __ ] lives in mississippi
if he's got a [ __ ] license to drive a
bus this is coming to get coming
together
right now
over me
and then we got to send it there and we
got to make sure
everybody gets the water
i don't want to go down there and like
only [ __ ] you know
it's going to be oh you didn't give any
of the white people you [ __ ] son of
and then starts all that [ __ ] up is
everybody come down
um all right drinking okay let's let's
let's see if we can make that happen
that was exciting
you know what i'm a really busy guy
lately
and i look at all planning with dread
that was [ __ ] euphoria that whole
thing because i was at the end of the
day you're gonna be doing something good
granted i'm just sitting here talking
i want to [ __ ] ride in on the water
truck like george kennedy in that
[ __ ] movie before the guy pushed him
off
was that the dirty dozen um all right
80s versus 90s music hey billy bass drum
just listen to the uh
september 8th thursday podcast and love
your description of the 80s and 90s in
american music
the 80s being the big bombastic come up
in the 90s being the somber moody
comedown
in england though it was kind of the
opposite in the 80s you had the dreary
downer stuff like the smiths sorry
hiccups
or jesus and mary chain
um
killing joke
i'm living in the 80s
i love that [ __ ] song um then in the
90s
you had big bombastic cocaine loving
bands like oasis
singing happy uplifting
anthems and everyone was up
everyone was up
cool
pretty brittania oh cool britannia they
called it at least until diana died and
killed the buzz yeah that was a buzz
kill
um granted both of our
by the way they showed the queen's
funeral like she drove i don't know how
[ __ ] far there was like thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of [ __ ]
people
like 20 deep
the whole ride up
[Music]
you know you think you're an influencer
with your little [ __ ] instagram page
uh granted both of our depictions are
just sweeping generalizations and there
are exceptions in both decades on both
sides of the pond of course but i still
thought it was an interesting
observation from a dumb angry balding
ginger i'm not a balding ginger i am
bald well i shaved my head
i still got some on top but it wasn't
worth mentioning
you know it ended up on the cutting room
floor sorry
did i mention i directed something oh
look at you bill oh well lonnie freaking
da
um just thought you might be interested
another field goal and he [ __ ] missed
it he [ __ ] missed it
he [ __ ] missed it
jesus christ
just when i was sitting there going why
the [ __ ] did the the goddamn raiders
they're going they're going to go for
two here who's 24 19. they're gonna go
for two so then they're only down by
three it's like why don't you kick the
extra point then the next time you get
the ball if you score a touchdown you
could be up by three
if we're just gonna play hypotheticals
here
well no cause then you know if you score
a touchdown you can go for two and then
you're tied
like this whole [ __ ] thing going for
two and shrugging it off like it's no
big deal you're just leaving points
you're just leaving points
on the ground instead of up on the
scoreboard that that just it's just not
good the only reason why it's working i
feel these are my fault for me i feel is
because everybody's doing it
um bill we get it we get it you'd kick
the extra point and wouldn't go for two
all right anyway he says just thought
you might be interested in the
difference of the scene since i know
you're a big music nerd like me i
definitely am
and um
i never really got into like
the smiths or um
or uh
oh wait a second i missed the whole
paragraph here
in england though it was kind of the
opposite the smiths jesus married change
and all that said margaret thatcher is
[ __ ] over the working-class music
oh that's what they had in the 80s all
right then in the 90s you had the big
bombastic cocaine loving [ __ ]
sorry this comes in threes there's
nothing i could do
i know there's another sneeze in there
um
um all right where are we here uh
younger girlfriends
all right bill
uh it's been a busy
few weeks for all the saints throwing
judgment at mr dicaprio
uh the disdain coming from the jealous
female and the [ __ ] move comments
coming from the [ __ ] move males is off
the charts yeah i mean i don't like
i mean if you had the ability to date
the most beautiful women in the world
you would
like ladies if you had the ability uh
you don't give a [ __ ] about men to
[ __ ] have the all the most beautiful
bags in the can we shame you for how
many [ __ ] those [ __ ] bags you're
gonna have in the goddamn closet
all right you guys like bags and shoes
guys like [ __ ] don't get mad at guys
because they like what do you what are
you supposed to do what is he supposed
to do
all of those women that he's dated i
didn't hear any of them complaining [ __ ]
off let the guy live his goddamn life
especially the men acting like they give
a [ __ ] about those women they don't
they're a bunch of [ __ ] haters
all
right anybody who can go out and and and
consistently decade after decade be out
there banging the most beautiful women
in the [ __ ] world who are all adults
i you know i i don't i'm cheering that
on
whatever makes you happy
and ladies if you want every [ __ ]
birken bag out there and you don't give
a [ __ ] what child had to sew it together
then god damn it i think you ought to
have it there you go is everybody happy
all right um it said it's a success let
me see something it's a successful man
who by all accounts has been nothing but
respectful wants to date from a
different generation then by all means
shut the [ __ ] up it's hard out there for
leo he doesn't have the privilege of
meeting girls with
any anonymity he's been as he's been in
several healthy relationships with
several healthy young women who have all
continued on with their careers and i
salute them yeah like there's no
it'd be one thing if everyone was saying
he was an [ __ ] there's none of that
so
hang on i gotta get some water
oh just a good old boy
oh i'm sorry is this some more liquid
death i believe it is in a nice cool can
looking like a light beer for miller
look at tampa bay look at him just
running downhill don't kick a [ __ ]
field goal
whatever you do
yeah i'm a big believer in minding your
own [ __ ] business and if the people
involved aren't complaining then you
shouldn't be
they always and it's always why the
[ __ ] women always paying attention to
what the [ __ ] somebody else is doing
that's just all
jealousy that's all that is i swear to
god if he was banging [ __ ]
25 year old ugly broads no one would
give a [ __ ]
who'd be sticking up for them nobody
um all right gathering wood
am i am i crazy uh dear bill greetings
from germany hope my english is good let
me start by saying i traveled to see you
in london at royal albert hall and it
was amazing um well thank you for doing
that because i needed a lot of people to
show up that night and um
that is just something i still can't
believe i got to do
um yeah
jesus christ
get me goosebumps just thinking about
that place okay here we go you may have
heard
about what is going on in germany's
energy crisis
our price of energy has gone up 10 times
our country has a very hard winter ahead
i've taken up tasks to
store lots of wood in every place
available on our property my wife's
family thinks i'm insane because they
have faith in the same people that put
us in this position
yeah you know it's always good to hedge
your bet
uh my wife's sister you want you know
you just sit there going hey i hope i'm
wrong i hope i'm wrong
then they can make fun of you and all
your [ __ ] you know piles of wood
hopefully that's what happened
um
my wife's sister told our nephews that
i'm crazy and one of them even called me
that to my face
they don't know anything about what's
going on in the world or what's coming
for our country
should i let them stay warm in the house
with all the wood i've gathered
at the end of the day yeah but i'd make
them knock a couple extra times
if they they have to say that you're not
crazy before you come in
and it's not all right you're not crazy
no no no no uh it's got to be longer
than that
it's got to be longer than that
uh i missed a family birthday because i
had
wait i missed something should i let
them stay in after when i would give i
should also say that i've driven hours
every week picking up affordable
firewood i missed a family birthday
because i had to do it during my time
off and couldn't go any other time so am
i crazy
and should i welcome them over if they
don't have heat for weeks in the
freezing temperatures
um i don't think you're crazy
like everything is [ __ ] crazy until
[ __ ] goes down
um
so
yeah i don't i don't think you're nuts i
think uh
i actually think you're smart
then at the end of the day you don't
have to you know nothing happens then
you don't have to shop for [ __ ] wood
for years
and um
i don't know just try to look at the
positive side that they think you're
nuts that just means they've
lived a very great life that they can't
even fathom something like that
happening
um
yeah i don't know i don't know all of
that [ __ ] is just like heavy stuff i
feel if your gut's telling you you
should do that and if you're informed
you feel you're informed and you feel
like this is the thing to do then i
would do it and there's there's no harm
in being wrong
all right
that way
if you're wrong the other way then i
don't know what
you [ __ ] freezed to death like jack
nicholson the end of uh
uh weekend at bernie said what the [ __ ]
was it called
the uh the snowy hotel
psycho killer keska
the shining all right ocean plastic
aka snowy hotel that was what is first
called
ocean plastic everybody
hey billy redfish
one fish two fish redfish bluefish i
like that hey billy redfish
no need to [ __ ] about the plastic in the
ocean is 75 percent
or more
uh from industrial fishing
what is that i don't know what that
means
good news you using plastic drinking
straws isn't endangering the fishies nor
is it the sole cause
for all the horrors in the world bad
news i love how this person is just
speaking with this level of authority
with nothing to back up anything these
are just sentences
bad news
it's still there and we have absolutely
no way of stopping more from being added
more good news boyian slat a kid from
holland started a company to clean up
the oceans he's used automated robots
which go to the garbage patch of heavily
polluted rivers and collect up plastics
he
then has it
has it taken back to land to recycling
processing plants
we need more guys like that more bad
news
more garbage is added faster than slats
robots can remove at the moment
even more good news
he's expanding his fleet and
can remove 50 000 tons a trip
which takes a couple of weeks
ending on good news all right
the plastic in the ocean is 75 or more
from industrial fishing
i don't think that's true
that swirl of trash in the middle of the
[ __ ] pacific
that's like two miles deep two and a
half times a mile deep two and a half
times the size of [ __ ] texas last i
had the nerve to look at it
i didn't see a lot of fishing poles in
there
i don't know what it is
all i know is it's there
and it gets into the fish and then you
eat it so i'm a reverse pescetarian i
don't [ __ ] with fish anymore unless it's
man-made salmon
all right
then all i got to worry about is some
scientists just in it sick [ __ ]
um
all right
is that the end of the podcast i believe
it is i believe it is it's nine to three
this is really enjoyable i had a good
time and uh i'm now gonna call uh my
buddy
and try to figure some [ __ ] out here
i'm gonna call my bus driver and i'm
gonna call [ __ ] uh
my buddy here i'm gonna see if i can get
a couple of trucks why not why let's do
something
let's do something positive
instead of blaming liberals and these
[ __ ] conservatives i think that's the
answer people maybe if we all gave a
[ __ ] a little bit huh oh i wish i could
play the piano right now
you know just sing a song
make you all feel
you know
guilty
as i somehow put myself above you even
though i haven't done [ __ ] for anybody
um all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves
incomplete pass go [ __ ] yourselves and i
will talk to you i'll check in on you on
thursday